This man is Rob Spence and he makes films.
No, literally, his body makes films.
After a shooting accident when he was nine,...
...Rob had to have his eye surgically removed.
But after joking with friends about having a robotic cyborg one installed instead,...
...documentary maker Rob actually went and did it.
Pretty much anyone who loses an eye will make a joke.
At least I should get a camera put in there.
It's not a wacky, out of this world concept.
Years of hard work and research have left him with this.
A tiny camera implanted in his eye socket which transmits video wirelessly...
...to screens, TVs, hard drives and cameras.
And it has opened up a whole new perspective for him,...
...even getting him offers of, and surprisingly secret, camera work.
One very high up news executive said would I like to go to Iraq...
...with my prosthetic eye and see what I could see there...
...because sometimes when you have a giant camera, it's not such a great idea in a war zone.
But instead, sci-fi fan Rob went around the world making a documentary on cyborgs...
...alongside the makers of the computer game Deus Ex.
That game features a cyborg from the future.
Here's one from today.